[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend wer
den Schaden hat braucht für den Spott
nicht zu sorgen mit dem Verweis auf
diese Volksweisheit hatte Bundeskanzler
Scholz ja seinen augenklappen-outing
selbst ironisch kommentiert ähnliches
könnte er auch über das heizungsgesetz
seiner ampelregierung sagen weil sich
die Koalition darüber selbst so zerlegt
hatte und das Ganze zu einem solch
mühseligen und verwirrenden Gezerre
wurde hat die Opposition da ein leichtes
Spiel und hat das bei der Debatte heute
im Bundestag natürlich auch weiblich
genutzt aus Berlin Frankfurt
die Gelegenheit war günstig und die
Opposition hat sie genutzt es geht um
harbex heizungsgesetz am Ende einer
langen haushaltswoche und so gerät die
zweite und dritte Lesung des GEG im
Bundestag zu einer weiteren
Generaldebatte
sie befördern Wut Frust Verdruss im Land
ihr heizungsgesetz ist ein
vertrauensverlustgesetz das ist das was
sie anrichten sie sind ein
Konjunkturprogramm für die Populisten im
Land das ist das eigentliche Problem ein
entsprechenden Ton hatte die AFD vorher
bereits angeschlagen sie zwingen uns
Bürger gegen
jede das uns verarmt und enteignet ohne
irgendeinen Nutzen weder fürs Klima noch
für die Menschen
Vertrauensverlust der Vorwurf begünstigt
erstaunliche Allianzen auch die
Linkspartei beklagt in diesem Verfahren
missachte die Koalition des Parlament wo
leben wir denn das ist eine Missachtung
meine Damen und Herren eine Missachtung
wo ist eigentlich ihr Selbstbewusstsein
Parlamentarier von SPD grün und FDP sie
lassen das einfach so sie zerstören
Akzeptanz und Vertrauen bei den Menschen
die so gescholtenden
Koalitionsfraktionen wären sich Kontern
mit Sachargumenten
und zu sagen wir nehmen das sogar noch
mal zurück das ist Misstrauen das ist
kein Vertrauen in Zukunft und das ist
das was sie hier heute gemacht haben der
Tod der Debatte aber bleibt scharf die
FDP kalt zurück vor allem in Richtung
Union dieses Land das hat doch mit
planwirtschaftlichen Ansätzen in den
letzten 15 Jahren seine Erfahrung
gemacht an keiner einzigen Stelle haben
wir sinnvoll die Klimaschutzziele
erreicht diese Koalition will die
Klimaschutz erreichen und das mit
Marktwirtschaft in Verbrennung bringen
Herr Heimat das ist der Unterschied
zwischen Ihnen und uns liebe Kollegen
Kollegen der CDU-Abgeordnete Heilmann
hatte vor dem Verfassungsgericht eine
einstweilige Anordnung gegen das Gesetz
erstritten empfindlicher Rückschlag für
die Bundesregierung der verantwortliche
Minister lobt sein heizungsgesetz wenn
abstrakte Vorschläge jedoch konkret
würden dann verändere sich die
öffentliche Diskussion
ist natürlich etwas ganz anderes den
Kohleausstieg bei den Atomausstieg zu
beschließen oder einen Gebäude
Energiegesetz wo wirklich Millionen von
Haushalten konkret betroffen sind dass
das eine andere Debatte ist eine
schwierigere eine Debatte die Sorgen
verursacht das ist in der Tatsache er
nehme diese Sorgen sehr ernst sagt
Harbeck dann noch das Gesetz aber
schütze die Bürger vor steigenden
co2-preisen der Praxistest dafür steht
noch aus der weite Weg vom Wunsch zur
Wirklichkeit in der Politik hoffentlich
nicht
das gehört Zerre um das heizungsgesetz
und die vielen anderen
koalitionsstreitigkeiten sind auch keine
große Hilfe für jene Vertreter der
ampelparteien die gerade im Wahlkampf
sind in Hessen und Bayern für beide
Länder hat die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
ein Politbarometer extra erstellt in
Bayern fällt da vor allem der Stimmen
Zuwachs der Freien Wähler ins Auge wenn
an diesem Sonntag Landtagswahl wäre käme
die CSU nur auf 36 Prozent die Grünen
ebenfalls mit leichten Verlusten auf 16
gleich auf die Freien Wähler die damit
um mehr als vier Prozentpunkte zulegen
würden auch die AFD könnte ihr Ergebnis
steigern auf 12%
. die SPD verharrte bei mageren 9 und
die FDP würde nicht mal mehr die fünf
Prozent würde schaffen
Markus Söder kann mit so einem Ergebnis
natürlich nicht zufrieden sein zwar
wünschen Ihnen sich 54 Prozent der
Befragten als Ministerpräsidenten und
der CSU wird bei Themen wie
Bildungspolitik und Wirtschaft mit
Abstand die größte Kompetenz
zugeschrieben aber bei der
entscheidenden Sonntagsfrage zahlt sich
das nicht entsprechend aus darüber habe
ich mit Markus Söder vorhin gesprochen
und ihn auch gefragt war warum die
flugblattaffäre nicht ihm sondern Hubert
Albaner nutzt zuvor aber die Reportage
von Jutta sonnewald und Christoph Wiesel
die dem Aufwind der Freien Wähler
nachspüren
das neueste Umfragehoch beflügelt Hans
Friedl heute beim Wahlkampf in Germering
westlich von München als Direktkandidat
der Freien Wähler für den Bayerischen
Landtag sieht Friedel sich in seiner
jahrelangen kommunalen Arbeit an der
Basis bestätigt
die bürger-song
die dann wenigstens für uns da die
können wir ansprechen die sagen bei
Vereinsfesten dort ist aber bei
Versammlungen Mitgliederversammlungen da
sind die Freien Wähler da und die sind
nicht so abgehoben auch ergibt sich als
Volksfreund gerne auch mal mit
rebellischen Zügen Hubert Aiwanger
letztes Wochenende bei einem
Bikertreffen in Niederbayern die Affäre
rund um das Holocaust verhöhnende
Flugblatt scheint ihm nicht geschadet zu
haben im Gegenteil der freie wählerchef
sieht sich als Opfer jetzt noch fester
im Sattel als zuvor die Bevölkerung
solidarisiert sich mit uns weil sie
sehen dass hier eine Kampagne gefahren
worden ist um die Freien Wähler um auch
meine Person zu beschädigen sie sehen
sich mit Umfragewerten von 12% ebenfalls
im Aufwind die AFD in Bayern heute beim
Wahlkampf mit ihrer Spitzenkandidatin
Katrin Ebner Steiner im
niederbayerischen Dingolfing in der
flugblätterfähre hat sich die AFD zwar
hinter Aiwanger gestellt doch sehen Sie
die Freien Wähler eigentlich als
konkurrentenrecht der Mitte Huber hat
sich das auf die Fahne geschrieben dass
er unsere unsere Wählerstimmen der AFD
abjagen möchte die Wähler sind in Bayern
derzeit dabei zu sondieren wollen Sie
wirklich Aiwanger wählen die Schein
Opposition oder gehen sie doch zum
Original zu der Alternative für
Deutschland nagen nun schon zwei
Parteien am rechten Rand der CSU sowohl
die AFD als auch die Freien Wähler
sprechen Menschen an die in den Christ
sozialen das verhasste ist derlismen
sehen doch AFD und Freie Wähler in einen
Topf zu werfen gehe zu weit so die
Politologin Jasmin Riedel die Freien
Wähler würden auf keinen Fall den
Klimawandel leugnen wollen auch
klimapolitische Maßnahmen durchsetzen
sie wollen nicht die EU auflösen und sie
sind einfach keine rechtspopulistische
bis zum Teil auch rechtsradikale
Parteien so sieht es auch Markus Söder
der im Wahlkampf Werbung macht mit
seinem Idol Franz Josef Strauß und
dessen Motto wir wollen mit
rechtsradikalen Narren und Extremisten
nichts zu tun haben dennoch muss er sich
die Kritik gefallen lassen mit aiwang in
einem Vize festzuhalten der Vorwürfe
einer möglichen rechten Gesinnung als
Gymnasiast nicht zweifelsfrei entkräften
konnte dafür steckt die CSU nun mit 36
Prozent in einem Umfragetief und Söder
in einem Dilemma wir werden genau
beobachten welchen Weg die freien Werder
weitergehen was das jetzt möglicherweise
an Veränderung gibt aber wenn ich an
unsere Kabinettskollegen denke auch auch
die Staatssekretäre viele viele
Kommunalpolitiker das sind eindeutig aus
in der Mitte die verankert und die
Freien Wähler werden am Ende ihren Weg
selbst Söder hat sich mit seinem
alternativlosen Bekenntnis zu Aiwanger
und den Freien Wählern von ihnen
abhängig gemacht nach den heutigen
Zahlen mehr denn je nun muss er
aufpassen nicht vom politischen Treiber
zum getriebenen zu werden
und der bayerische Ministerpräsident ist
uns aus Nürnberg zugeschaltet guten
Abend
guten Abend grüß Gott man sich dieses
Politbarometer extra anguckt diese
aktuelle
stimmungsaufnahme dann scheint das als
hätte diese flugplatzgeschichte haben
alberner genutzt und ihnen geschadet wie
bitter ist das für Sie
jetzt zunächst mal kommst Du darauf an
dass wir diese Affäre abgeschlossen
haben ich habe eine schwere Entscheidung
zu treffen gehabt und man sieht ja auch
im Politbarometer dass das
Krisenmanagement insgesamt von der
überragenden Anzahl der Bürger geschätzt
wurde was die Umfrage jetzt betrifft ich
glaube dass viel so Solidarisierung drin
das war eine sehr auffüllende Wochen die
letzten zwei auch für die Bayern und
deswegen gab es für Solidarität aber ich
glaube das wird sich auch in den
nächsten Wochen möglicherweise wieder
verändern für uns ist sicher noch ein
bisschen Luft nach oben drin in anderen
Umfragen legen wir deutlich darüber aber
die sind alles nur im Moment Aufnahmen
ich glaube was entscheiden ist es geht
in Bayern jetzt nicht nur eine Person
sondern um 13 Millionen Bayern deswegen
ist meiner Sicht das ganze abgeschlossen
und wir konzentrieren uns auf das was
entscheiden ist nämlich die Zukunft des
Landes ja sie hatten das ja heute in der
Pressekonferenz auch von Fieber Kurven
gesprochen durch die man das erklären
kann aber die Freien Wähler waren schon
vor Wochen als es noch gar keine
Flugblatt Affäre gab im Aufwind da sah
das schon nicht so sehr viel anders aus
also kann das allein ja keine Erklärung
dafür sein dass da ja die Freien Wähler
auch ihnen offenbar Wähler wegnehmen
ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt weil wenn
Sie alle Umfragen sehen über alle
Institute hinweg klar das zdforientiert
sich an seinem eigenen umfrage-institut
sozusagen aber über die ganzen Umfrage
Weg war die freien Wetter relativ stark
zwischen 11 und 12 Prozent das war das
Ergebnis bei der letzten Landtagswahl
und dass sie normalerweise wenn man fünf
ja dann regiert dass der Opposition
heraus mein Prozent oder zwei zulegt das
ist nicht so überraschend viel
überraschender ist dann aber jetzt halt
gewesen der jetzige Schub nach vorne
aber der kommt aus meiner Sicht aus
dieser Fieberkurve aus dieser
Solidarität aus dieser
stimmungsgeladenheit der letzten Tage
das glaube ich aber wird sich oder kann
sich noch sehr schnell ändern weil am
Ende kommt sie auf eine Sache an wenn
sie die Charts sehen im Politbarometer
werden ja zwei Fragen auch stark
gestellt wer hat die Kompetenz in den
zentralen Fragen beispielsweise
Wirtschaft das ist die CSU und die
wichtigste Frage vielleicht wen wünschen
sich die Bayern als Ministerpräsident
und das ist ein ziemlich deutlicher
Wunsch gerade im vergleichen und am Ende
das komisch ist nur dass es dann
trotzdem oder Mehrheit der wählen kann
Entscheidung getroffen aber warum sind
es dann nur 36 Prozent das ist noch
schlechter als das historisch schlechte
Ergebnis bei der Landtagswahl 2018 und
damals haben sie von einer politischen
Nahtoderfahrung gesprochen eben auch
weil sie merkten dieser Versuch der AFD
2018 als sie sagten das waren politische
Nahtoderfahrung in diesem Bereich
Nahtoderfahrung war nicht das Ergebnis
sondern die war lange zuvor als wir bei
Umfragen waren drei Tage vor der letzten
Landtagswahl hat uns die gleiche
Forschungsgruppe sind weniger gegeben
war damals die Zeit und eben nicht mehr
darauf gesetzt um die AFD quasi ja der
AFD hinterherzulaufen auch damaliger
Generalsekretär hat gesagt ein stinkt
hier über stinkt man nicht das waren
Fehler jetzt stellt sich die Frage und
nun ist der Albaner ist nicht die AFD
aber es geht ja auch um eine Umarmung
Strategie und die Hoffnung dass man mit
ihm zusammen ist das am Ende dann eher
ihnen nutzt wenn er sich in der
Regierung auch ein zaubert aber
erscheint durch diese Koalition immer
stärker zu werden im Gegensatz zu ihnen
zunächst nochmal um das einfach mal zu
klären die ganzen verschiedenen
Argumente entscheiden ist für uns wir
haben auch das letzte Mal kein
schlechtes Ergebnis erzielt wir haben
eine andere Situation wir haben das
erste Mal 2018 bei der Landtagswahl eine
AFD gehabt 20.13 hat er das nicht und
AFD in Freie Wähler zusammen sie haben
es angesprochen haben heute Prozente die
auch bei Edmund Stoiber und anderen
damals natürlich die Wahlergebnisse
verändert haben wir müssen uns auf die
neue Zeit einstellen dafür ist ein
Ergebnis in der Nähe der 40 ein
zumindest aber mal belastbares Ergebnis
zweiter Punkt wir sagen ganz klar wir
wollen auf keinen Fall Schwarz-Grün weil
wir eine klare Distanz zu der Ampel
zeigen die Ampel hat in Bayern wegen
ganz Deutschland jeden Bezug zur
Bevölkerung verloren sie ist gerade zu
offline zu dem Empfindungen der Menschen
und handelt auch weitestgehend gegen
Interessen viele Menschen jedenfalls
empfinden die das so und vor dem
Hintergrund ist ganz klar kein schwarz
grün das garantiere ich auch ganz
persönlich und wir wollen die
bürgerliche Koalition mit den Freien
Wählern Fahrzeugen und jetzt kommt halt
in den nächsten vier Wochen es sind noch
vier Wochen an einfach noch mal klar zu
machen was entscheiden
diese Solidarität der letzten Tage die
verstehe ich auch die ist auch in
Ordnung haben auch übrigens viele CSU da
gezeigt weil wir einfach gesagt haben
die Entscheidung des ministerins richtig
und jetzt kommt es darauf an klar zu
machen wer hat die Kompetenz wer führt
an und wer es auch die entscheidende
Kraft 100
unterbrechen darf um auf das
zurückzukommen was sie eben sagten auf
keinen Fall Schwarz-Grün sie haben sie
noch stärker formuliert die
schwarz-grüne Gefahr in Bayern ist
gebannt die glaubwürdig ist das
eigentlich wenn das sie oder auch Herr
märz um die Grünen quasi als
leibhaftigen an die Wand waren malen
aber in sechs Bundesländern
unionsministerpräsidenten oder
Unionsparteien ganz unproblematisch mit
den Grünen zusammen koalieren in Hessen
ist ja auch gerade Wahlkampf man hat wie
ist das für ein rein wenn sie sagen grün
geht gar nicht der Kollege mit denen
ja das ist ja Hessen weil wir sind ja
Bayern und in Bayern entscheiden wir
eben anders und ich habe das letzte Mal
so entschieden auch das letzte Mal haben
sich die Grünen Angeboten zum Teil auch
angebietet und wollten unbedingt in die
Regierung wir haben auch Gespräche
geführt und haben damals schon
festgestellt da gibt es keine belastbare
Basis das hat sich noch vertieft das
Wirken der Grünen in der Ampel diese
ganzen Fragen die die vielen deutschen
Menschen einfach nerven diese Frage was
darf man essen und und
ähnliche Dinge mehr lassen Sie mich doch
ganz kurz
und ich will Antworten
auf diese strategische Frage ist es
glaube das ist ein großer Teil also
diese Macht Option zu nehmen und zu
sagen auf gar keinen Fall niemals
ich glaube dass das die Zuschauer
interessiert manchmal sogar mehr als
noch die fünfzehnte Zwischenfrage
interessiert die Zuschauer was denkt
eigentlich jemand den man in interviewt
und deswegen möchte ich den Gedanken zu
Ende entwickeln bei uns in Bayern wir
damals gesagt wir machen nicht
Schwarz-Grün wir machen jetzt auch nicht
Schwarz-Grün sondern wir werden eine
bürgerliche Koalition fortsetzen die
übrigens auch nicht an einer Person
denkt und wir haben gute Ergebnisse
erzielt Bayern geht besser als nahezu
allen Bundesländern also never change
winning Team und deswegen ändern wir das
nicht setzen weiter auf eine
Zusammenarbeit natürlich ist ganz klar
das war jetzt eine Belastung das hat das
Ansehen Bayerns auch herausgefordert und
deswegen sind doch die Freien Wähler
gefordert aus deren Ferien
Herausforderung kam diesen ansehen
Verlust aufzuarbeiten ich habe
jedenfalls eine stabile Regierung
geführt über viele Jahre und habe die
Stabilität in diesen schweren Zeit noch
erhalten danke
sehr gerne
für die Landtagswahlen in Hessen gibt es
wie gesagt auch ein Politbarometer extra
und das sieht in der Sonntagsfrage wie
folgt aus die CDU mit Ministerpräsident
rein würde auf 30 Prozent zulegen der
grüne Koalitionspartner liber relativ
stabil 19 Prozent gleich auf die SPD mit
Spitzenkandidatin väser die AFD käme mit
Zuwächsen auf
16%. die FDP müsste etwas Federn lassen
wäre mit sechs Prozent aber im Landtag
vertreten die Linke mit 3% hingegen
nicht mehr
beide Politbarometer extra mit allen
Fragen und Ergebnissen können Sie online
abrufen auf ZDF heute und jetzt erstmal
die Nachrichten
Vandalismus Schäden sind laut der Bahn
Grund für Zugausfälle auf der Strecke
zwischen Hamburg und Berlin sowie
Rostock an drei Orten in Hamburg sein
letzte Nacht Kabelschächte in Brand
gesetzt worden so die Polizei ein
Bekennerschreiben auf einer
linksextremistischen Internetplattform
spricht von Verkehrsadern der
kapitalistischen Infrastruktur die man
sabotiert habe laut einer Bahnsprecherin
sollen die Störungen bis morgen früh
andauern
rund 3000 ehrenamtlich engagierte
Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus ganz
Deutschland waren heute bei
Bundespräsident Steinmeier eingeladen
zur Eröffnung des Bürgerfestes dankte
ihnen Steinmeier im Park seines Berliner
Amtssitzes Schloss Bellevue für ihren
Einsatz und sagte sie stünden für die
vielen die unser Land tagtäglich
zusammenhielten
in den flutgebieten in Griechenland
gehen die Rettungsaktionen weiter
hunderte Menschen sind heute in
Sicherheit gebracht worden seit Anfang
der Woche hatte das Sturmtief Daniel für
Regenmengen in Rekordhöhe gesorgt
mindestens zehn Menschen sind in
Griechenland ums Leben gekommen
zahlreiche Dörfer sind noch immer von
der Außenwelt abgeschnitten die Schäden
der Flut sind enorm experten sprechen
von Kosten in Milliardenhöhe
schwere Regenfälle haben auch in
Hongkong zum massiven Überschwemmungen
geführt Straßen und U-Bahn-Stationen
sind geflutet worden Erdrutsche
Blockieren verkehrswerke der Nahverkehr
wurde eingestellt Schulen geschlossen
die Polizei teilte mit das mindestens
zwei Menschen ums Leben gekommen sein
und mehr als 100 weitere verletzt wurden
wenn sich die Staats- und
Regierungschefs der G20 am Wochenende in
Indien treffen fällt natürlich vor allem
auf wer nicht dabei ist Wladimir Putin
den vermisst allerdings auch keiner auch
jene Staaten die mit Russland weiterhin
freundliche Beziehungen pflegen wissen
dass seine Anwesenheit diesen Gipfel
gesprengt hätte was allerdings wie ein
Paukenschlag wirkte war die Absage des
chinesischen Präsidenten das ist vor
allem für den indischen Gastgeber ein
Affront zumal Indien bei diesen Gipfel
auch seine eigenen Machtansprüche
demonstrieren möchte Eindrücke aus Neu
Delhi von Normen Odenthal
[Gelächter]
wenn die Anspannung wächst hat sich
sogar bewährt Lachyoga am besten so
macht man es in Deli und Indiens
Hauptstadt hat ja in der Tat einiges vor
sich strecken und recken in Höchstform
will hier jeder sein das ganze Land
Indien setzt in diesen Tagen Maßstäbe
wie man sein Land der Welt auf
internationaler Bühne präsentiert
Mister Modi hat den G20-Gipfel nach
Indien gebracht zum ersten Mal er
leistet großartige Arbeit für unser Land
er ist sehr fähig ich wünschte jedes
Land hätte einen derart fähigen Anführer
wie Mister
ist der Vorturner der Nation zeigt sich
beim Yoga so beweglich wie auf der
politischen Bühne
einzelsport-mannschaft Sport für sich
allein und doch gemeinsam mit anderen
wer will kann darin auch den Rhythmus
modischer Außenpolitik erkennen
es geht darum die Unabhängigkeit des
eigenen Handels zu bewahren und doch
gleichzeitig eine Führungsmacht im
internationalen System zu sein die zwar
eingebunden ist und andere einbindet die
aber nicht als purer Empfänger globaler
Regeln und Ideen agiert sondern selbst
regeln und Ideen einbringt
Selbstbewusstsein Indien strotzt nur so
und nicht zu Unrecht symbolisch die
jüngsten Erfolge in der Raumfahrt im
siegestaumelträumen viele vom
unaufhaltsamen Aufstieg der Nation
Indien ist nicht nur dabei Indien ist
voll
in diesem wunderbaren Moment gratuliere
ich meinen 1,4 Milliarden Landsleuten
die meine Familie sind ich gratuliere zu
ihrer harten Arbeit ihren Talent indien
hat den Südpol des Mondes erreicht
keinem anderen Land ist das vor uns
gelungen
auch in der irdischen machtarithmetik
will Deli nun zeigen dass es ein Faktor
ist die Stimme des globalen Südens der
Gipfel ist die Gelegenheit der Gastgeber
wird von vielen Seiten umschmeichelt was
eine Menge Optionen bietet aber auch
Fallstrecke
die Risiken sind enorm Russland und der
Westen Rasseln aneinander China und der
Westen Rasseln aneinander China und
Indien Rasseln ebenso aneinander und
dann kommt dieser Gipfel zudem weder
russlands Präsident noch Chinas
Präsident anreisen die Botschaft ist
klar die Welt wird immer polarisierter
und Indien muss gut überlegen wo es
steht
und die Welt muss überlegen welchen
Partner man mit Indien gewinnt riesiger
marktwirtschaftsmotor Atommacht aber
zugleich ein Armenhaus mit extremen
sozialen Spannungen dazu der
hindu-nationalistische Kurs der
Regierung Muddi der Minderheiten das
Leben immer schwerer macht
ein komplexes kompliziertes Land also es
wird nicht leicht mit Indien aber so
viel scheint klar ohne Indien geht gar
nichts mehr
mit das schwierigste Thema beim
G20-Gipfel wird der Umgang mit Russlands
Krieg gegen die Ukraine sein ob es
gelingen wird dazu irgendeine Erklärung
zustande zu bringen bei der aus Russland
zumindest alle anderen unterschreiben
dass der Angriff auf die Ukraine
eindeutig verurteilt wird das dürfte
wohl eher unwahrscheinlich sein die
ukrainische Armee sagt unterdessen dass
sie bei ihrer Offensive weiter
vorankommen vor allem in der Region
saporicia ein wichtiger Erfolg war für
Sie die Einnahme der Ortschaft robotine
dort hatten sich die russischen Besatzer
hinter besonders stark befestigten
verteidigungswellen verschanzt Henna
Hebestreit war bei ukrainischen
Stellungen nahe der Front
gegen mancher Eindringlinge ist selbst
das ukrainische Militär machtlos
wir sind im vorgeschobenen Posten eine
Aufklärungseinheit südlich von SAP
Reker so sein kampfname beobachtet mit
seinen Kameraden russische Stellungen an
der Front
Drohnen liefern solche Bilder rund um
die Uhr
im Moment haben wir die Situation unter
Kontrolle der Feind versucht jetzt keine
Gegenaktionen manchmal beobachten wir
wie sie sich irgendwo weiter entfernt
sammeln für einen Angriff heute sieht es
nicht so aus als machten sie Druck auf
Roboter
und so haben Sie etwas Zeit von sich zu
erzählen der Metro ist Offizier und
Fernsehen Moderator im Zivilleben hat
der Olympische Spiele kommentiert und
als Kampfsportler sogar mit alien
errungen
ich denke Kampfkunst und Krieg haben
viel gemeinsam es ist nur so dass der
Krieg mit moderneren Waffen gekämpft
wird und das ist hier leider keine
Regeln gibt
wer hier draußen ins Gefecht zieht
kämpft nach seinen eigenen Regeln Kasper
und Direktor so ihre Rufnamen führten
einen Stoßtrupp bei der Befreiung von
robotinien
auf dem Schlachtfeld musst du dir
ständig sagen dass du überleben willst
das ist das Wichtigste
glaubst du du könntest sterben wirst du
das auch tun und deine Kameraden müssen
dich vom Schlachtfeld holen das ist
keine gute Variante
damit auch dem Schlachtfeld möglichst
wenige zurückbleiben setzen sie Drohnen
ein zur Aufklärung aber auch als Waffe
wenn sie Granaten über solchen Gräben
abwerfen und zuschauen was da unten
passiert
ich mache nur meinen Job um mein Land zu
verteidigen wenn man Emotionen und
Ehrgeiz in dieser Arbeit mit einbezieht
ist das der schlimmste Feind du kannst
da nicht mehr denken
ihre Welt hier draußen ist klar
strukturiert den Freund und Feind und
für ihn in das Essen streitig macht
sollte schon ein Mäuschen sein
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz mit Wirtschaft und dem
Blick auf die Apple Aktie ihr Kurs ging
in dieser Woche mehrere Prozent nach
unten hat inzwischen aber auch wieder
etwas davon wett gemacht bei der was ist
da der Hintergrund das ist vermutlich
die Retourkutsche für das huawei-verbot
der Amerikaner das noch auf die
trumpzeit zurückgeht auch die Ausfuhr
bestimmter Computerchips und Maschinen
haben die Amerikaner untersagt ganz klar
mit dem Ziel Chinas Aufstieg
auszubremsen nun das Verbot der Eifer
uns in einigen chinesischen Behörden und
Staatsunternehmen mit der Begründung
Sicherheitsbedenken da wird mit harten
Bandagen gekämpft das trifft den Konzern
China ist nach den USA Apples zweit
wichtigster Markt der bislang etwa ein
Fünftel des Umsatzes ausmacht
entsprechend heftig zunächst die
Reaktionen an der Börse ein Minus von 4%
in dieser Woche rund um die Gerüchte
eines möglichen Verbots Apple Gerät nun
also zwischen die Fronten der
amerikanisch chinesischen
Auseinandersetzungen die Sorge ist dass
die Amerikaner auf das verboten mit
einem Gegenschlag reagieren könnten was
den schwingenden Handelskonflikt mit
China weiter verschärfen würde für Apple
jedenfalls für China mehr und mehr zum
Risiko
vielen Dank
Dressurreiterin Jessica von Bredo Werndl
hat bei der Europameisterschaft ihren
Titel im Grand Prix Spezial verteidigt
einen Tag nach der EM Silbermedaille mit
der deutschen Mannschaft dominierte die
37-Jährige die erste von zwei einzelne
Entscheidungen und das deutsche
Basketball-Team hat es geschafft ins WM
Finale und da spielt es am Sonntag gegen
Serbien um den Titel zu sehen hier im
ZDF ab 14:15 Uhr erreicht hat die
Mannschaft um Kapitän Dennis Schröder
dieses Endspiel durch einen
Halbfinalsieg gegen Olympiasieger USA
der Moment als alle Dämme brechen
erstmals steht ein deutsches basketball
team in einem WM-Finale und das nach
einem wahren Krimi gegen die mächtigen
USA
stehen wirklich und jetzt das erste Mal
Finale stehen USA geschlagen haben ist
einen komfortablen 12 punkte-vorsprung
hätten die Deutschen beinahe noch
verspielt Anthony Edwards verkürzt den
Rückstand der US-Amerikaner auf drei
Punkte eine hektische nervenaufreibende
schlussfase in der Andreas Obst kühlen
Kopf behält mit 24 Punkten bester
Korbjäger und Kapitän eines Schröder
übernimmt Verantwortung so bleibt es am
Ende beim deutschen Vorsprung einem
knappen 113 zu 111 wirklich jetzt werden
Finale
also besser witzig ich hoffe ich hoffe
es wird noch besser das meine ich dann
nämlich wenn Serbien am Sonntag im
Finale geschlagen werden sollte
Sensation von uns was das für heute
weiter geht's mit der heute show die ist
zurück aus der Sommerpause und um 09:20
Uhr gibt's dann unsere heutigen Update
mit einer sanktür mir morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird ein
spätsommerwochenende denn das Hoch
Patricia hält noch ein Weilchen durch
und wird sie erst Anfang der kommenden
Woche Richtung Osten verabschieden dann
übernehmen immer mehr Tiefs und sie
sehen schon da sind eine ganze Menge
Tiefs im Westen schon unterwegs heute
Nacht ist es meist klar hin und wieder
bildet sich etwas Nebel und die
Temperaturen sinken auf Werte zwischen
17 Grad am Niederrhein und 10 Grad in
Bayern und morgen liegen dann die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 26 Grad im
Allgäu und 33 Grad am Oberrhein es gibt
also meistwerte um die 30 Grad ja und
deswegen gibt es morgen auch sehr viel
Sonnenschein bei einem schwachen Wind
aus südlichen Richtungen vielleicht
gibt's im Nordwesten mal ein paar
Wolkenfelder und aus den Alpen heraus
vielleicht am Nachmittag mal eine
quellwolke das bedeutet auch dass morgen
die Waldbrandgefahr hier im Nordosten
recht groß ist und das bleibt sie auch
am Sonntag denn der ändert sich das
Wetter gar nicht das bleibt nach wie vor
sehr sonnig bei Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 26 und 33 Grad aber diese
Temperaturen werden sinken bis zur
Wochenmitte erwarten uns dann nur noch
Höchstwerte zwischen 18 und maximal 26
Grad und das Wetter wird sich auch
gravierend ändern denn spätestens in der
Nacht auf Dienstag setzen dann von
Westen kräftige Regenschauer und
Gewitter ein und dann ist der
Temperatursturz da ich möchte Ihnen noch
einen Hurrikan zeigen Hurrikan Lee hat
sich entwickelt das ist ein nature
Hurrikan das bedeutet er hat eine der
höchsten Kategorien vier oder fünf in
ihm treten Windgeschwindigkeiten über
250 km pro Stunde auf und er wird wohl
nördlich der Karibik erstmal
weiterziehen ob er dann die
US-amerikanische Ostküste trifft
behalten wir im Auge guten Abend